so I think Steptoe is worse here's why I
mean look both of these are Shockers but
the initial pain of a stub toe to me is
far greater than the initial pain of a
paper cut and though the pain of both
Fades there's one thing you can do with
the stubbed toe that is not even a
variable with a paper cut which is you
can break your toe once you have an open
it's an open wound versus hitting
yourself and then there's like a walking
it off but with a paper cut especially
if you get it in a horrible place like a
hand that's active or a place that bends
a lot it just keeps reopening reopening
get infected it's burning you can have a
paper cut look at that you can have a
paper cut a week after you you cut your
hand look at this oh god oh right
because when people stub their toe all
bets are off yeah okay well then you
don't do that with a paper cut here's
the other thing that a paper cut won't
do